Rowdy Roddy Piper had a book come out
and he's doing an autograph signing in
Times Square me and my buddy Brian Quinn
from the show we went to go wait and we
waited on this line to meet him so I get
up there and I said I'm like oh I'm such
a big you know huge fan you know I said
I just you know one of my Fondest
Memories of my of my father is comes
from you and he looks at me and he
starts crying Roddy Piper his eyes
filled with tears and he starts crying
and he gives me a hug and his son's
right there and he hears it and he looks
at his son and he looks at me and I was
like oh my God and he starts crying so I
was like I got teary-eyed and I start
crying like he hugs me and I'm like yeah
man you know it's just really nice and
he goes I'm so sorry when did you we
lose dad
he's crying and I'm crying I go oh my
dad's in the car
I don't know my dad's home ah